Hi there! Welcome to the Super Family's 10th movie, Prepare for the War.
Well, first off, before we go to some rules, I know we do it every time, but some of you don't watch it every time.
Alright, um, some new members are Bruisey and Whitestripe. They're a bruiser cruiser and a limo.
They're gonna join Ruby, Blackie, and Berry.
And, um, another set of them is Nupar, another one is Nuparo, a Bionicle, and a little Tohunga.
He's gonna, um, um, he's gonna, uh, um, he's gonna, uh, he's gonna be, um, Pohatu's little baby.
I mean, Tohunga? Okay.
Now, now, two new little members that were just born from Matthias and Cornflower.
Now, Mikey, here you are, these two little munchkins.
This is Jewelize, and this is, um, Emeril.
Last one is the Transformers, okay?
This is a Transformer right here, one of them.
Alright, and they can transform from a vehicle to, just wait a second,
set the legs right here.
Alright, another one is, they're kind of hard to see.
Um, right here, here's one.
You take that, you split it, whoop,
split it, you turn it back.
Alright, one special feature of these little guys, I know it will take a while, but,
is, now this is just,
I'm just showing you the normal stuff. Now, you see, just normal Smokestream, and he's got
lift towards his mini-con. When he attaches to him,
there's a special thing, it opens up.
And, well, that's kind of cheap, but this is just the toy that the kids play with.
Thanks, Amanda. Alright, Amanda with her rules.
Yay, I like playing with this. This time, I'm gonna get it right.
Okay? No smoking, no flash photography, even though
you don't really need to. Cameras. No, like, playing with Scream, no
screaming, yelling, um, turn all your
cellphones off. If you can't do that, then don't take them along.
Um, make sure everybody can see.
Everybody's really happy. Okay.
...returning home from a meeting at the, at the meeting of all ravens, to see
if the universal war will be or will be not.
Get ready. Cookies are finished.
She's a brilliant child, but he wants this.
And candy! A misadventure made good. Alright, back to the movie.
We stand together until Mata Nui
is free. What a great book.
It's about the Tahu and the others. Woo! Okay,
okay, okay, okay, here I come. The bad news is,
we're gonna have a universal war. Ain't no snow out there!
Oh my gosh!
The good news is, I came across some rats,
and they said, it stinks in there.
And rats think every, think,
most stinky things smell good. Yep. How about you
come in and get some hot cocoa? Is it cold out there? Yes! It's
cold! Okay, calm down. Do the
breathe.
You have to do it now, you need to calm down occasionally.
Okay, whatever. I have too much business
to do. And you got mail. Have you seen the kids lately? No.
Sparky, do you know where Stacy is? Stacy's
upstairs getting dressed. You kids want to make some breakfast? I want you to do
it because it's fun. Did I mention the war park? Stacy.
The war park. Why can't we just have a relaxing time?
I'm gonna go tell Stacy to know she's gonna come down and have some breakfast.
Donuts, we got pink cream sprinkles,
and sprinkles. Doesn't that
look scrumptious? It's not cooked yet.
You munchkins want their dinner? Want some? Too bad. Here's the babies.
They're not gonna jump on the table. Just a minute. I have to
ask you something. Why does mom always rush people to get dressed?
I need help and blow dry my hair.
Is your little... It's spinach.
Oh, I forgot. You have school with the kids.
Bet that's hectic. When do they come? When do they come
to school? Breakfast. I think they've already had breakfast
upstairs. Okay, I'm gonna go down my shirt. Now,
remember the two best children today.
One, get in your seat.
Take your seat. One, take your seat.
Gorgeous
so I don't think he'll be able to make it.
Baby, um, Malice.
Oh, but she wasn't talking.
She was lip syncing. Hey, it's Snakey!
We have got to get some... Just wait a second,
kids.
Mom, he's always absent.
He's a helper.
Get off! Catch him!
They're gonna get punished. Don't try this at home, kids.
Especially with your pet. Loving animals.
This is a normal lizard who's gonna have a fat problem
after I'm finished.
This is how far his tail stretches with me.
And, guess what I'm gonna let loose on him.
That's right, Baby Sam.
Okay, everyone.
I'll write some problems.
Okay, Baby Sunstrike.
Kids, you got a new toy.
Baby Sam, he'll tear up your shreds.
Don't try this at home.
No. I'm talking to
the children.
Kids, now, can somebody
please tell me one of
these four
problems? Women. It's a
It's almost time for
kids. It's not morning.
Just a minute.
I gotta teach them.
Okay, kids. I can turn him into
a crocodile. Teach here.
Okay.
Which one of these four... I'm trying to teach
This one. Two times five.
Which two
of these two times five
equals...
Baby Sunstrike. What's the
first one here?
You're gonna
hit him.
Which one doesn't
belong here? The only one that
the buttercups don't call out.
Two minus
two equals
but that is right.
I'm gonna do this.
You're gonna rip him.
I'm gonna
put this on our camcorder.
It's a family moment.
See right there? It looks like his hand.
It's like a fossil.
Oh, you missed it.
You don't have as good heating as we did.
Perfect. I knew dinosaurs
could be fossils.
They're not lizards.
Can I get the lizard down? No.
Please. It's on the floor.
So don't get this one.
No, don't whack him.
Do not touch this.
This is a fossil.
Oh, I missed.
Hey, kids. You want me to do
something really disgusting? Right here.
Just kidding.
Okay, time to get to work.
Leaves a good mark.
Around the pole.
I'm Tracy. I'm Stacy.
I'm Stacy.
I thought Bella taught lessons.
Or is she sick?
She's taking care of Scorch.
Because she's a plumber.
Hey, you hit me in the face.
There's consequences for that.
You cracked his skull.
I think you cracked everything.
I'm gonna crack your skull against this world.
Including the board.
I think it's dead.
I think it was already dead.
I think the kids keep playing
with the skull.
No, bring this in for show and tell.
This is my dead
pet.
Lizard. Pet.
It's my dead pet.
My dad beat up on it.
I'm gonna wrap you around here forever.
Hey, stay around there.
I'm gonna wrap you around.
Just stay there.
I'm gonna rip you to shreds.
Okay, kids.
There's some fossils.
You kids seem like you're in college,
but you're only in second grade.
You're already doing fossils.
Still learning to do that.
Yeah, I know.
But it seems like...
There's it. It's fresher.
Let's get it.
Okay, kids.
Here's a fossil.
Are you forgetting something?
What?
I've got a pokey gun.
Oh, no you don't.
It's late at night.
It's time for the kids' baths, you know.
Why can't they just skip baths tonight?
No.
Okay, they can.
Hey, kids.
Do you want to go watch a movie?
Oh, man. We've been in the school room for a while.
Man, do you want to see what it looks like now?
Yeah, it's still late at night.
It's 12.35.
What day is it today?
I said the lights hurt my eyes.
Oh.
TV remote.
Is it backwards?
I don't think so.
Except in the cup, whatever's left in there.
Whatever beans are left in there.
Oh, all the coffee beans are in that little
container next to the sink nozzle.
But then
they turn
into coffee.
Yeah, I advertise that. I hate those.
They're real coffee.
Here's a gift for you, Kopaka.
I hope you won't mind if I keep it chilled
for later.
No, no, no. It hurts my ears. Don't do it.
I like that part.
Why aren't the kids up yet?
Because it's like animals on a base.
It's not like them.
Hey, it's the dead lizard.
And why do my clips keep
falling out?
Don't eat them.
Punishment.
Hello.
I like making bloopers.
I was just waking up with a lie that
a mop was sitting on.
Here we go.
I forgot.
Um, in order to
prepare for the Universal War,
we have to
get the Bohrok call.
Well, I'll tell you about them.
Okay, um,
the Toa and the
Turaga have to search for
all the, uh,
for all these, um,
uh,
they need to search for these platinum masks.
I wonder what they're for.
And some more masks for the Toa
and Toa Nuva.
Plus,
the Bohrok Vaughn need to
find more crowns for the Bohrok
and find these mysterious
silver crowns.
I don't know what they're for, but
they're supposed to be really great.
Oh, in the morning?
Alright, I'm gonna set up battle plans
so we can send the Toa off.
A couple years ago. You can do school.
In the kitchen!
We gotta set up battle plans.
There's Tahu.
Breaks.
Violets.
Cards.
Try to be a little quiet.
You're still sick, huh?
Uh,
um,
on the board, go to that page in your math book.
There we go.
I'm on vacation now.
Do the kids hear that? Do the kids hear that?
They're too busy looking for the math book.
Okay, kids.
Now, startin' your math.
Um, I'm gonna be
eating my breakfast.
Gotta eat hurry.
The problems?
I'm on vacation.
It's so nice there all the time.
And I'm trying to eat my pear.
I mean, my lemon.
The rest of my lemon later.
Okay, kids.
Who's ever done
just, um, 30 of my books up here?
Okay? There's a big pile.
I'll check these.
Um, you guys can read a book
quiet.
Here's your math book.
Now, do you guys know what
time it is?
I can't find that other card.
Not that.
I stand for daily.
But I stand for individual.
Reading time.
Daily
individual reading time.
Yes.
And daily individual reading time.
And the stuff that you get in your
yard, too.
Dirt?
No. It's the letters in the
accord. It's like, daily individual
reading time.
Guess what? Dad told me when he was in school
that he had a teacher named Mrs.
Mintzel, and she had this
dirt daily individual
reading card. Can't they read?
I gotta hurry.
Why doesn't that fit there?
That's what Makuta says.
Why do people, when they're
people talking to themselves,
why do they just say it in their head?
One of these islands. No wonder.
Some gum.
I like chewing gum when I'm
Here we go. I had it placed
wrong. Okay,
Stacy, um, do you like me?
Do you have recess soon?
They're having playtime right now.
They're gonna recess after lunch.
No.
I need time with you, quickly.
Sure, um,
just a minute.
We're gonna have to figure out where
are all the Bohrok and Bohrok
collar.
Okay, when I'm done hitting my nails.
Finally, I'm finished.
And you can
just go do something until I'm done hitting my nails.
Huh?
No, we gotta
do it now.
If Academy was painting her nails,
and she was in the Super Family,
she would say,
I have fabulous nails today,
I have to paint my nails.
There's a glare on it. We can't have
glares.
How do we change the glare?
Change this.
Okay, I'm gonna be at this end.
Alright. Where should I
Um, they won't be getting
any hair in this area. You should be right here.
Alright.
We have little markers of the Toa.
Right.
How's that?
It's been in like a half a year.
Mom's still growing her hair back.
Yeah, cause
And I bet
the bat riders are picking out their teeth.
Yeah, they're not revived yet.
They're trying to get the um
They're trying
to get uh
the Bohrok call before we are.
Okay, you're controlling
Okay, choose some Toa.
Don't I look weird?
Choose some Toa to take. You control them.
Okay, you chose the opposite team.
We both chose Toa Kaita.
Cause these are my three favorites.
Yeah, and they're both on the same Toa Kaita.
Alright.
Now.
Go straight to their villages.
Yeah.
No. Just pretend these are the Bohrok.
Alright, um.
They'll each go to their villages.
I think it's somewhere around Anukoro.
So I'll put it right there.
Should I put that here?
Yeah, cause that's in Galakini.
Wait, no.
Should I put Galakini in there?
Yeah, that's Gakoro right there.
So.
She goes around to Gakoro.
Alright, um. All the, well.
Just pretend these are the Turaga.
They're gonna go around with each Bohrok
on Va and search
for different coronary of mass.
And we can especially look for the
different, um, types.
And the Bohrok are going
to search for the
the, uh.
Um.
Bohrok call.
Okay? So I'm going
to, uh.
Call them.
Okay.
No, just. No, stay over here.
One hand painted and the other not.
Alright.
We need Tama.
Am I going on an adventure?
Yep.
Can I at least take one finger?
Yay!
Sure. Okay. We're gonna send you now because we're
running short in time.
We lost our lid.
We're here. Well, I know that.
I don't think you should come with me little bro.
Aww.
You gotta go with, um.
You have
to go with, uh.
Oh, what's his name?
Um, Vakama?
Yeah, you gotta go with Vakama
because you gotta search for all
the, um.
The, uh.
Thingies.
Yeah, the Platinum Mask for the Toa.
Okay.
Here's your Fire Staff. You can take
the case. Stinger, attach!
I'll take all my
Krana.
Here's the cover.
See? Got Cognouva on it.
Oh, it's upside down, but.
Oh, you can't see him.
Alright, see ya.
Gotta get a Krana in.
Eee!
Which one should I wear?
My favorite one.
It's been a while, hasn't it?
Eee, my head snaps back faster.
Cause I got the strength
Krana in. Oh.
Kinda hard to see, but. Now we gotta
search for Toa.
Toa not call.
Wait a minute. We got
his Krana, so I think we can awaken him.
Wait a minute. I think I got it here.
Eee, in my backpack.
Gimme. Eee.
I think this is his.
Wait a minute.
See, it's like
bronze colored, like.
Alright. You ready?
Wee!
There I am. There's the
Bohrok. I see it
already. Eee! Let's go!
There it is.
Wow, it looks really different.
It's gonna follow me.
There's the Bohrok.
Activate him. I need his
Krana. Wherever
it is. He doesn't have a Krana.
Here's the Krana. I need to activate him.
Purify!
I gotta put it in my own head to purify it.
So he doesn't
become evil.
That's a bad thing when they become evil, you know.
Hey, I look funky. Alright,
now it's purified.
Cool.
Urge not to help them. I'm Tarnok.
I've come to, uh,
uh, uh, uh,
bring you to the Superfamily.
Why would I want to join them?
They are the enemies of the Barag.
Well, because they're good.
The Barag do not want
you to serve them. No.
They hate you.
Why should they hate me? I'll
destroy them. What's this
Superfamily like? Well, it's like,
uh, it's a convention of
little and big
people and they, um, protect
the universe and stuff. Ooh, I
can still use my powers? Sure.
Yes, I'm going
to join.
What's your name? T-T-Tarnok
Ka.
Hmm, we both stammer.
Heeey.
You stole my name.
Counterpart, like, um, what
Tahu, Nupa, and Tahu.
Y-Yes. Um,
do you want help? Sure, but
what's your power first?
Electricity. Holy
crap. When we go
in the Universal War, we're gonna win.
First, we gotta find Nuvok.
If you want to, um, stop the
Universal War, we're gonna need Nuvok.
Ka.
Okay, let's
go. These are my friends
right here. They like watching us.
Oh, but
they're, uh, they're people.
I detest people.
I like them. Alright,
alright.
Alright.
Let's go. Hi, guys.
I turned on my night vision
so I can see.
You can do. Where is that guy?
What's that?
I need, um,
um, Tarnok Ka's
superior sight.
Tarnok Ka!
What? I was sleeping.
What'd you need?
What was that?
There's somebody down here.
Scary noises. Scary noises.
Hey, my head
looks all shiny.
Hey, you can't see my marking.
Favorite marking.
Oh well.
Night vision.
I got the night vision crown in. That's why.
What do you see?
Super
night vision!
You see him?
Right there.
Alright, turn off super night vision.
Now we see him.
Let's go.
Come on, Tarnok.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Can't open it. We gotta find this chrono.
To awaken him.
I don't want us to fight anymore.
I joined the super family.
Then I guess I should.
If you did.
Hey, what's your power?
Super family, this is my power.
I can't move.
I'm stuck to the ground.
I can loosen gravity.
Too fast.
Now I can return gravity to normal.
We better get out of here.
What's that?
No, I'll magnetize him to the ground.
Who are you?
Did you know that I'm black?
I got gravity shield.
You wanna see my chrono?
It's really shiny.
Gotta turn off night vision.
No, don't turn it off.
We won't be on the sea.
Can you still see me a little bit?
Can you see my chrono?
Just a little bit.
It's kind of orange, just like.
Oh well.
Alright, time to go find, um.
Um, what's his name?
Paracal.
See ya.
Oh, yeah, like that.
Bye.
Welcome to the super family.
We did it back in the power time.
But now.
Um, what are you gonna be singing?
Um, I'm gonna be singing.
I forget what number two is called.
I mean, after number two,
we're gonna like change our music up
and we're gonna sing I Love You.
We might sing one more song.
We might sing this twice, I don't know.
Alright, don't start it yet.
Alright, alright.
These are my background singers.
Introduce my background singers.
Oh.
Background singers are these two little
members that are in
Lego Step Rally and they're going to
become members of the super family.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay. Ready?
Not yet. Ready. Set.
Go.
Is Parac anywhere?
No Parac?
Well, we got a long hike until
the desert, you know.
I know that.
Whoa, guys, break it up here.
Hey, he's a Paracal.
And he loves to scrunch up.
That's what Makuta does.
That was like
the fifth time we met.
No, fourth. No, fifth.
Oh, whatever.
Hey, did you see that falling down the waterfall?
What was that?
Looked like some kind of Krama
of some sort.
Hey, this looks weird.
Hey.
This is Galax
Krama. Hey, ooh, I dropped it.
Krama.
And she's the only Borak Kal that doesn't have a
uh,
a mask of
um,
uh, special thing.
Yeah, like I do. You wanna see?
Here it is.
Got it. There we go.
Alright.
What's that?
It's at the top of the waterfall.
Kal.
It landed.
Let's open it up and use the Krama to awaken her.
Okay.
We gotta purify the Krama.
Borak, you will, okay?
I feel like magnetism thingy.
Okay, now we're ready to activate her.
You need your Krama.
Thank you.
Do you feel like you gotta go help the Barrag?
I want to.
Because that's what Borak Kal wants to do.
But you wanna join the Super Family.
If you gotta join the Super Family,
you can still use your powers.
Uh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You said Borak Kal
are supposed to go join the Barrag,
but you said
go join the Super Family.
We were, we were evil,
but Tanakh saved us.
Yeah.
What's your power?
What does that do?
Okay.
We both lost our Krama.
You wanna come with us?
We're looking for the Borak,
the other Borak Kal.
Is there any other girls?
Yeah, Korok.
Let's go.
Well, guys, welcome to the jungle.
Be here like all buggy and stuff.
Hey, Galak.
Hmm?
Why don't you do the honors?
You gotta go get the crocodile.
Okay.
Here comes Lavok.
Hey, he's already out of his case,
but into his head.
It wasn't purified.
Oh, great.
I'll get you.
Barrag, here I come.
I'm going to awaken you.
Barrag.
It's kind of boring.
You can't pick it up.
That's good.
I'll suck in all the air so you can't breathe
in a blast that can shatter solid rock.
Electricity.
We can't touch it, so we can't move the wall.
Tree.
Well, that's kind of cheap, but oh well.
Bastion on the head with plants.
The sides of your hand.
Ew, it isn't.
You said that.
Who said that?
It's the same thing.
Evil people always say,
Why do you awaken me from my slumber?
I heard you.
I'm making you to find Colin the Cuda.
I'm good. I'm with the super family.
I'll make your teeth stick together.
Magnetize his neck to his back.
Take his weak spot out.
Magnetize it to the button
that you're protecting
for no apparent reason.
They're tricking us.
They are trying to lock their weak spots
so we can't take them out the next time we battle.
Remember to use all of our powers wisely.
Because I don't have my power shield.
We both look funny, but we don't look funny
without our power shields, so I'll just
give mine to you and then you won't look funny anymore.
Why do we have to keep talking about funny?
Yeah, it's funny.
Now do I look funny?
I'll just put it behind my back.
You look like you don't have an arm.
I can't take my Chrono out.
I'll join the Cuda.
Vision.
And its psychic powers.
Magnetize.
Must wear it.
Give it to him.
He'll be able to awaken the Batarang.
You cannot.
You need to come with the Super Family.
They're better than the Batarang.
The Batarang hate us.
They do?
Even if they don't hate me,
I'm still going to work for the Super Family.
Yay, your power shields are getting back.
Good, you need a treat.
What's your power?
Vacuum Blast.
I can suck in all the air in an area
and blast it like a shatter solid rock.
Yeah, you said that before.
Well, um, you don't want to know.
I have some friends that want to see you.
Tadoc, wake up!
I could have just reached and put your comment.
Like I just did.
You just stay down there and protect the forest.
I'm going to introduce him to our little friend.
Our very little friend.
Hey, guys.
This is Slaybok.
Hey.
Um, I like my head.
It's all shiny.
Alright, see ya.
Remember to say,
Alright, everybody, say,
say, um,
the word
on one, two, three.
One.
Welcome to the Super Family's
Oh.
Here comes the Super Family's
next part
thingy.
Um, we're going to do
you tell. Okay.
We're going to do, I love rock and roll
and then pop.
Um. No.
We're doing, I love rock and roll, um, singing
and then we're going to do number two, dancing.
Then we're going to do, um,
pop singing. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Um, introduce my background
singers. Again. I have
eight girls,
four boys, and altogether
that's 12. Okay.
Baby Ella at the lead is
Bunny Ears Baby Ella.
Next is, um,
Butch Boomer and Brick. Butch Boomer
and Brick, yes. Then
it's Baby,
um, Baby Rockin' Teresa.
Then it's Super
Scorch. Then
Blockin'
Bubbles. Then
Blossom. Super Blossom.
And,
um, Pyro
Buttercup. Then it's
Baby, who?
I'm just getting the necklace.
Baby, um, Constance.
And then it's
Baby Malice.
I can't see. Oh, Baby
Malice and
my number one helper,
Sunny Strait.
Super Sunny Strait.
Alright, let's get moving.
Hehe, get a room. I'm the DJ.
Alright.
Turn it on.
Okay. Let's go!
Hehe.
She threw it back on the stage.
See, I got it. I got it.
I got it. I got it.
And you don't. Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Kick him off the
set. Huh? What you doing?
My background, but, um, you can go sit in your
seat. Alright, begin.
Pop live in
Mexico, baby.
...
Okay, next question.
You have to
tell us. I don't have a favorite.
You're a...
Wow.
...
I have the power of plasma.
I'll melt your chronic-
...
I'm not a crummy in a bowl, I'm a star.
Do you like my shiny head?
Can you see it?
Okay, good.
Hey!
Look at my shiny head.
Now I'll show you.
I'm gonna magnet my head onto it.
Oh!
Gonna start.
I'm gonna call a Zot Call on you so I can be awakened.
Once you join the super family, I'm on you.
I got a big nose.
Very, very.
Actually, it tastes like chicken and meat.
Just you take a bath.
You know, even the good guys can smell bad, you know.
Why I take chicken bath?
I bathed it.
You can't do that, you'll fall asleep.
It's drink caffeine.
Caffeine.
My floor right here.
Don't touch my weak spot.
No, you can't do that.
We locked our weak spots in.
They're harder to get out.
Hey, what are you doing?
My line isn't working.
There are weak spots where she tastes good.
I taste like poop.
No, she tastes like poop.
She tastes like chicken wings.
Chicken wings.
She was supposed to taste like poop.
Oh, it's like Nora.
I'm going to throw all the Boracol away.
Hey, I can't bite.
Roll attack.
I'm supposed to be a Swiss roll.
Kind of like Swiss cheese?
No, it's Swiss roll attack.
You gotta take your stinger off
if you want to become a Swiss roll.
Swiss roll attack.
Still tastes like chicken wings.
I put a stick in my chest.
My weak spot's supposed to go.
Did you see that?
Oh, that could take a week.
Stinger.
I lost my thingy.
What are you doing?
I'm taking them.
Oh, my God.
You must get in hard, hard, hard.
Bolt thing in the back?
No, my feather.
That's kind of like my tongue.
Your eye's coming off.
Oh, you.
I can take a look though.
Give of them.
Not be imprisoned.
Defeated by a lower class minion by you.
You are just normal Borac.
There's nothing special about you.
I'm running.
I, I, I lost my thing, thing, thing.
What are you doing?
I'm running.
You, you stupid idiots.
You aren't even powerful enough.
You're not even more powerful than me.
Yeah.
You're weak spot.
Absorbing.
Tastes good.
Absorbing it.
I'm absorbing it.
So powerful.
I feel more powerful.
I feel something, something around here.
A force.
Very powerful.
Something.
It's McKinney.
Why are you wearing that mask?
And she's not.
She is not.
Talk to us.
It's my turn.
I'm about to do it.
Throw it.
He threw it.
If he couldn't, they said something about the seventh Toa and stuff.
Yeah.
That's it.
I guess we're going to go home now.
We defeated them.
Oh, you're the Toa.
Yes, you are the Boracal.
We are mangled and stuff because we are just in our case.
It looks like you're the Boracal.
It looks like we got to go now because, well, they found out that, um, okay, people, you
see us up there?
Well, yeah.
What's that?
We don't have our gold masks anymore because we have platinum masks.
Platinum.
I thought you said, I didn't say plaque.
Because if they were, if they had plaque, they'd be black.
I don't know what I'm doing here, but, um, yeah, you guys got all the Boracal.
Where's Tanoc?
Uh, he's sleeping.
All right.
Uh, you guys can, like, leave now because.
And now, a special announcement from Tahu the Toa.
Hey, guys.
It's been a while since I've seen you.
Come over here.
It's an underwear lighter.
See ya, guys.
See ya.
See ya in the Universal War movie.
This one's going to be awesome.
We found all the Boracal.
And who do you think's going to win the Universal War?
That's right.
Us.
And you.
Because you are going to help us by figuring out who is the seventh Toa.
Who is the seventh Toa?
Nobody knows.
We may figure it out in 50 years.
We may figure it out in 10 years.
Or maybe even tomorrow.
But then again, keep your eyes peeled for the Super Family's 11th movie, the Toa Nuva.
Wait a minute.
No.
The Universal War.
You've been hearing about it.
Now it's time to watch it.
See ya.
All right.
It's time to party.
The Toa Nuva.